the world of element City includes air
water Earth and Fire
in a clash it's
open hey sorry when you make a film
about elements you are just setting
yourself up for the puns
thought bubble maybe we play The Crying
Game let me guess you try to cry we try
not to cry oh honey you won't believe
what your baby niece did today she she
smiles no she didn't
Catherine O'Hara how can she make crying
sounds so funny
it was really fun to record
Pixar does something really special but
how did you guys actually do this
to be able to see all the different
characters pop out at you and really
come to life oh my goodness after seeing
my character we are total twins it's
like looking in a mirror two two
I think putting your heart into the
story is a big ingredient to what makes
a Pixar film work I've just never been
punched before
I think the only way to get close to
appreciating it is to see it on a big
screen it is fun it is funny it's just
so full of life this will just hit you
right in the feels that's what Pixar
does
[Applause]
the baby boy
seriously
[Music]